merci d'offrir à l'humanité ce moment
c'est un moment que tant d'hommes ont
rêvé de vivre une page de l'histoire se
tourne aujourd'hui
ce gars est au service d'un criminel je
ne travaille pas pour lui notre labo
travaille pour lui
tu seras gentil d'un maire claudie je
ferai mon boulot c'est tout je suis
journaliste
je suis des gens qui n'aiment pas être
suivi que pensez vous des rumeurs selon
lesquelles vous recruter des personnes
vulnérables pour réaliser sur elle des
expériences portel me sens chez moi
c'est de finir à ces menaces
vais apprendre à vous fondre dans le
paysage je suis loué à ce petit jeu mais
vous vous êtes une bille qui que vous
soyez
je travaillais à la l'iphone déchets
j'ai besoin de votre aide
on a trouvé quelque chose on les appelle
les symbiote carlton drake je pense que
l'association entre humains et symbiote
est la clé de notre évolution
fut malade comme un chien
j'entends une voix douce
départ et lt qu'une voix dans ma tête
vous avez quelque chose qui appartient à
monsieur greg tu sais pas
pourquoi on a fait ça
si tu veux rester avec moi tu ne feras
du mal qu méchant mois l'instant on n'a
qu'à faire d'accord
vous êtes prêt à sacrifier
la seule chose à laquelle vous tenez
j'ai vraiment être mort de peur
[Musique]
vous êtes quoi porter sur nous
son plénum